pour commencer, on peut déjà se fixer un objectif
tu attends toujours
Je pleure 32 semaines quelqu'un thérapie
stationnaire dans huit semaines on en fera un
premier examen pour voir si
thérapie frappe bastian avec ceux de
donner à l'avenir les infusions et les
accès sans soucis
Je les ai tous morts moi-même
environ trois semaines, nous allons
les cheveux dans le dos tu portes ça
pas dit comme ça maintenant
rouge
vous êtes sûr que vous avez la pièce uniquement pour
utilise ta barbe oui
je peux le faire
mes chers rêves maintenant elle craint
toute la station c'est ce qu'ils font
voilà bastien qui devrait faire ça
mon père sait tout sur le mien
maladie il recherche et veut tout
à savoir
aile rsn qui connaît mon chrétien
docteur mieux que moi
une possibilité de
même la liberté ne le fait pas ainsi
continue juste à vivre
totalement amusant fait ce jeu avec le
défiler et raconter
il est dieu
Oui oui